hello everyone and welcome to the
quarterfinals of this year's video World
Cup it is gookash versus Magnus Carlsen
this is the first decisive game that
finished and the gookish defeated Ivanka
in the previous round Magnus cross and
defeat the vasel evanchook it was a
great match for both of them but now
they face each other and of course the
goal is uh enter the semi-final so I'm
not gonna spoil anything let's check it
out it's quite a beautiful game googish
has the white pieces and he opens with
Pawn to D4 Magnus Ops for Knight to F6
and here we have Bishop to F4 uh opting
for the London system which is something
Magnus definitely hasn't planned because
here he was uh well he was sort of
surprised and he did take his time
deciding on his next move and there are
many moves you can play here you can go
for G6 you can go for D5 you can go for
C6 you can go for C5 you can go for E6
but Magnus goes for none of that he
actually plays Pawn to B6 which is like
the eighth most popular maybe in the
10th most popular air continuation and
it hasn't really been employed on the
top level level and uh mvl Maxima Shiela
used it a couple of times I think used
it three times in the Norway chess Blitz
in 2017 and he lost all three games so
the uh the the the uh the move order
Knight of six followed by B6 doesn't
does not have a great reputation against
D for Bishop to F4 but okay Magnus
thought that this would uh avoid
gooker's preparation and uh well it
wasn't exactly so so because played it
very very quickly here uh he continued
with knights the C3 uh with Bishop to B7
and now Pawn to F3 so basically now you
see that this game will be all about the
fight for the E4 square with E6 and
pawnte for gookers grabs the full Center
here and there are some games where D5
and Bishop to B4 were played but Magnus
goes for A6 and it is now already as of
move 5 that we have a completely new
game imagine that a move 5 in a
classical time format in in a tournament
of this uh importance a completely new
game that's okay Queen to D2 bookish
prepares the the castle Queen side and
pawn to D5 again going for the E4 Square
we have castles and now Bishop to B4 uh
well pinning one of the Defenders of the
E4 Pawn with A3 Bishop captures Queen
captures and now D captures on e4 and
now the question is what uh was googer's
plan is his plan to capture on C7 is
that is that the idea or is the idea
something else well let's see what
happens if you play Bishop captures on
C7 or queen captures it's a it's a fine
maneuver but then Queen to D5 now you
have to worry about stuff like Queen to
A2 so you're gonna play Bishop to C4 of
course uh Queen to G5 with check King to
B1 and now you can continue attacking
with B5 let's say let's say Pawn to D5
now at White can even sacrifice some
material here B captures and queen to B4
now you are preventing the black king
from castling but also how is uh black
saving that Bishop on B7 there is really
no good way to do it if you move it you
can just capture on B8 so we might as
well capture some something Bishop
characters on D5 never gonna win a Tempo
by attacking the black queen give a few
pawns Queen characters and G2 Knight to
F4 attack the queen again Queen captures
on F3 attack the queen again and once
the queen moves now we're gonna play
Bishop captures on V8 and you have this
very very active position where uh okay
a black is up a piece but also Black's
King cannot leave the center of the
board uh so it's definitely a trade-off
if anyone is to be preferred here it is
definitely white but of course the line
is not forced and um uh well it's just a
uh just a fun way to play sookish
instead goes Pawn to D5 and now we have
Knight captures on D5 Queen captures on
G7 going after the Rook here Magnus
offers a queen trade and bookish accepts
Queen captures Knight captures and here
when I saw this I thought okay a very
quick Queen uh trade like Magnus did
against Vincent kymer and then he just
lost terribly in round one is are we
going to see a repetition of that uh
well let's see Bishop to E5 forces King
D7 uh there is no way to actually defend
the knight any other way and only now
Bishop captures and C7 winning back the
material we have Knight Vita D7 and now
this should be back to G3 we have Rook H
to G8 here Magnus started playing a
little bit quicker uh and the bishop to
E2 continuing development you don't want
um to play something like Knight to D2
and then uh well uh allow something like
e captures on F3 talking back to E8 and
now F captures an E4 we have Knight
chapters and Bishop to F3 and here
Magnus just trades everything off Knight
captures on G3 and now bookish can
capture an H3 but he can also capture on
B7 he captured on G3 but just to show
you what happens if Bishop captures on
B7 attacks The Rook so you're gonna
attack the bishop but now H captures on
G3 Rook capture some B7 Rook characters
and H7 and Rook captures on G3 so equal
material uh if anyone needs to be
preferred here it's probably black but
again not much though not much to show
for here he does have he he's the only
one with the past Pawn so we should
prefer black a little bit here but
instead after Knight captures in G3 H
characters and G3 with Bishop captures
and F3 and now Knight captures on F3 and
now we have Rook captures on G3 if you
try to play active with Knight to F6
then you get something like Rook to H6
attacks the Knight and once the king
defends it now Knights the E5 and you
get this position where black is really
out of any good options you can't move
the Knight because the D7 check you
can't move the Rook uh at the d8 because
of Knight the C6 check picking up the
Rook so you have to go into this fourth
line of Knight to G4 and then let's
unite the C6 checking the E8 Rook
captures on H7 now Knight
uh Rook captures on H7 and that's pretty
much it then you get the Rook into the
game uh White is up upon it's a double G
Pawn so it's not spectacular but black
would get some activity for this
sacrifice Pawn uh but okay instead we
have rooked uh uh a rook captures on G3
by Magnus and now Rook captures on H7
King D7 and now Knight to D4 and here uh
we have Knight the E5 uh the reason why
Magnus didn't go for Rook captures on G2
is that if you go for this then Knight
the C6 check King to E8 and now Rook to
F1 will put pressure on this F Pawn and
now you can defend it okay you're gonna
play something like Rook to C8 put
pressure on the Knight but now it's a
dead draw uh we just trade everything
off Rook F captures on F7 you're gonna
play Rook captures on C6 Rook will kill
if okay you can first deliver a check
into a federal captures on D7 you're
gonna capture on C2 here and after
getting the D1 uh it's a very rare case
where you have uh the the two Rooks on
the second of your opponent's color and
the two Rooks on this on the 7 entering
and it's just a draw of course unless
one of them blunders mate like something
like this but of course that's not going
to happen so we're gonna have a draw by
Perpetual checking here so after night
the D4 Magnus decides to go for Knight
to E5 instead he says I don't want to
finish this game too early uh Rook to E1
attacking the Knight and now Magnus
plays Rook to G4 and here a Magnus
caught up on time a little bit uh it's
30 minutes for gukash versus 36 minutes
minutes uh for Magnus because Magnus was
uh doing it very poorly in the opening
he did they have to figure out how to
counter that London system properly but
now he definitely caught up and gokish
decides to trade knights we have
captures captures and Rook back to E2
defending the pawn here Magnus quickly
goes Rook a to d8 this is the movie you
play without thinking because if white
is careless of course Rook the D1 is
Checkmate so Lucas has the tent to that
of course he plays C3 he gives he gives
his King the C2 Square to escape to and
now Rook to F4 uh defending the pawn
here of course you don't want to just
attack that pawn for free King to C2 and
now Rook the G8 going after the G2 pawn
pawn the B4 by googash creating a safe
haven for his King on B3 and now Pawn to
B5 we have King to B3 and of course Rook
F the G4 now doubling up on the G file
uh Rook Dev 2 going after the F7 pawn
and now Magnus just defends it with his
a rook from G8 and offers a trade of
Rooks uh so Rook capture Sun G7 Rook
captures and G7 and now Pawn to A4 and
here Magnus plays Pawn to F5 so uh how
do you evaluate this position well
gookish is three against three on the
queen side if he trades all of them then
he gets a pass pawn and Magnus already
has a pass Pawn in the center of the
board so a capture some B5 a captures on
B5 and now uh Rook to A2 the biggest
problem for gookish is that he cannot
play C4 because it Rook to G3 checking
has to move and then you lose the C4
Pawn so gookish has to figure out how to
actually advance that fantasy for if he
can figure that out uh he might uh
survive this because make no mistake
it's uh it's a Magnus who will be
playing for the win here he does have
the past E Pawn bookish has the
permanent weakness in G2 and also the C3
is a backwards Pawn so seemingly out of
nowhere just trading pieces playing good
moves gookish is in a very very
difficult situation uh Rook to A2 Lucas
wants to go uh for Rook day 5 and go
after the pawn here and Magnus good
uh magnets could actually win the game
on the spot here but uh he he doesn't
find it uh but it's a you know it is
just a disgusting Engine line King to D6
and after King they Rook day five King
to C6 and now there's really no move for
white here where you you have to move
the real Rook day two and now Pawn to F4
and the white is auto moves here now
Magnus found this exact same thing only
through a different move order but in
doing so he allowed gukash the
possibility of a very very artistic
defense uh but only if he finds it and
hiragooker did not find it he played
Rook the A7 check but do you know what
the what the line is that well that
saves the game for gookash even feel
free to pause the video and try to spot
this line for gookish while I give you a
couple of seconds or you know just the
move
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being a true
defender of uh well uh barely defensible
positions And for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook the A5
again this is the only move that um at
the fence because uh well okay F4 you
defend the pawn and now the trick is to
give up the G2 Pawn you don't go back of
course you play King to C2 so unless you
have like a lot of time on the clock you
don't find this and googash was already
closing in on five minutes on the clock
point is that after we'll capture Sanji
to check King to D3 Rook to G5 now you
play King to E4 Rook the F5 defending
the pawn and now Rook the A7 check King
F6 now King to F3 and once E5 is played
you play Rook A6 check King to G5 and
now Rook the E6 and this is how you
defend the position uh you don't I'll uh
you have control over the E4 square and
your one Pawn is stopping both the B and
the C Pawn from advancing forward so
this is what Google has to find in order
to save the position but he played Rook
day 7 check and now he gives the magnets
that one crucial Tempo in this race
where he will just be well one one
square uh closer to actually winning the
game and also Lucas is now down to five
minutes on the clock Magnus has some 30
minutes on the clock over 30 minutes
Rook back to A2 defending but now Magnus
is just free to push his pawns F4 Rook
to C2 and now Rook the G3 we have King
to A2 uh gookish hoping to get that C4
moving but now King to E5 now c4 will
not be such a problem okay we can even
show what happens B captures B5 now King
D5 and now after B6 of course you don't
go after the pawn and allow Rook to B2
you have to play Rook to B3 that's how
you play it and now of course after Rook
to V2 it's not a problem we can just
trade captures captures and go after the
pawn and now with three pawns to one we
will easily win this game with black so
King to B2 again gookish repeats and now
we have King to D5 Rook to D2 with check
and King the E4 and here time control
has been reached by both of them this is
move 40 bookish actually left to the
board and he uh wasn't coming back for
for quite some time I think he was away
for like 20 minutes checking out the
other games I actually thought he was
going to pull a bar delay but uh he
didn't he came back and he played the
king to B3 uh we have Ponte E5 and now
Rook the E to check King to F5 we have
Rook to D2 and now Pawn to E4 you can
see how strong the past E Pawn is Rook
to D5 check King to F6 and okay there's
nothing better captures the pawn he does
have two connected pass pawns now but
magnus's pawns are too far away
now the problem is if Rook to B8 then E2
and if Rook to E8 then Rook to E3 stops
the rook and next move you get a queen
into the game so Rook the B6 check was
played with King to F5 and now Rook the
B5 with the check uh it's kind of a you
know a trait of every chess player to
you know give those last few checks
before actually resigning I don't know
why we do this it's uh probably because
you know there's this possibility of
maybe your opponent makes a really
really silly move or or maybe it's just
you know coming to terms with uh with
the inevitable Doom so it's hard to say
King to E4 we have Rook the B8 Magnus
played E2 and he was in this position on
move 48 that agukesh resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so both of them uh pretty much destroyed
all of their uh opponents In classical
chess only one of their uh games went
the uh the time breaks Magnus uh uh took
Vincent the tyrex and uh gookish played
Ty breaks against uh yes bank I believe
all the other games that ended the In
classical chess and so does this one
also in classical chess now tomorrow
bookish will have the the black pieces
and he will have to defeat magnets with
black which um well it's not impossible
but chances uh are you know definitely
against them but if you know if he wants
to win the World Cup if he wants to
qualify for the candidates that is
exactly what he's going to have to do
and that will not beat Magnus that will
just force tie break so the road ahead
is is a great one and here you resign uh
King to C2 for example you want to try
to stop the pawn doesn't really matter
King T3 You're Gonna Play rookie 8
checking F2 and now King E2 King D2
stops the pawn from coming to E1 but now
rookie 3 wins in all of the lines that's
pretty much it real capture spawn
captures that say that the King has
nowhere to go you have to move now E1
Queen you have a queen your opponent
doesn't that's all there is
uh so yeah very nicely done by Magnus uh
it was a pretty wild game uh first
glucose surprising magnets with the
London then Magnus going for this
offbeat B6 move uh that uh well uh like
I said only only been played by maximum
he lost three games in route one uh and
then uh played pretty much uh all the
moves all the perfect moves and the only
way to explain this loss is that he was
playing against Magnus cost and there is
nothing else to this then he was uh
double checking triple checking and
quadruple checking his moves spending
more and more time to counter magnus's
moves uh he went down in time and here
when he was just five minutes on the
clock it was already far too late you
know he even tried to defend this so
he's gonna try uh have to try something
else in the second game we'll see what
happens uh but yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed it like I said this is the first
decisive game that finished some of the
other games are very likely to finish
and we're gonna cover them as well uh so
do stay tuned for that uh so yeah uh uh
I would like to thank
nanoid Mario and sinosa and Michael shui
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the Fida World Cup until it
finishes uh so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day